[Music]
tip number 67 sports betting right now
you're trapped at home with your
children they're driving you crazy and
you want revenge simple because all live
sporting events have been canceled ESPN
is rebroadcasting some of the greatest
sports games of all time games where you
already know the outcome all you have to
do is tell your kids these old games are
happening live and then get them to bet
against you putting all of their
allowance on the team you convinced them
can't lose for example when ESPN
rebroadcast the 1980 Winter Olympics
miracle on ice hockey game where the US
team against overwhelming odds beat the
Russians you get your kids to get all
their money on a Russia and if your kids
get suspicious and ask why the footage
looks grainy and old just show them some
of my show and say see all television
made during quarantine looks bad and if
they say okay but why does it say 1980
Winter Olympics and why are the Winter
Games in April just tell them it was
postponed until now due to the great
pandemic of 1980 and if you missed the
game when it's shown on ESPN no problem
you can get them to bet on the 1981
made-for-tv movie Miracle on Ice
starring 80s actor Steve Guttenberg and
if they ask why does this game look like
a movie you've earned your place here
you'll know it I know it
now all of America knows it say
something like I don't know I think
they're just trying to keep up with
kwibi get off my ass it's a great way to
win money and crush your kids spirits
plus you look like a hero because you
family watching the game with them and
remember always have them venmo the
money cuz you do not know where that
cash has been morning they seemed bets
on old games only works on children
between the ages of 6 months and 4 if
any child older than 4 falls for this
you've got much bigger problems
let's get dinner
[Music]